ja ich muss heute sagen Respekt Robert
habe die Entscheidung ist erst wenige
Stunden alt Robert habe ich gerade
angekündigt dass er nach jetzigen Stand
zwei der drei Atommeiler in Deutschland
über den Jahreswechsel hinauf hinaus am
Netz lassen wir das überraschen denn
Robert Habeck steht in seiner Partei
massiv unter Druck nicht nur
Außenministerin Annalena baerbock auch
der altlinke und Grünen Strippenzieher
Jürgen Trittin hat in den letzten Wochen
und Monaten immer wieder gesagt
Laufzeitverlängerung nicht mit uns von
daher hat Robert habe etwas gemacht wir
haben das gerade auch schon diskutiert
vor einer wichtigen Landtagswahl die
Katze aus dem Sack zu lassen und zwar
die die sehr unangenehm ist für ihn und
vor allem für seine Partei das heißt für
ihn steht der Härtetest eigentlich
wirklich noch bevor es wird jetzt hart
für ihn in der eigenen Partei und er hat
natürlich zu Recht Begehrlichkeiten
geweckt denn nur zwei Meiler bis früher
23 laufen zu lassen das haben wir gerade
auch schon diskutiert das reicht
natürlich für die viert Industrienation
Deutschland überhaupt nicht aus alle
drei Meiler müssen weiter laufen und am
besten müssen zweimal davon denen die
stillgelegt sind zurück ans Netz Robert
Habeck hat jetzt die Chance zum
endgültigen Polit alphatiert zu werden
oder zum endgültigen Absteiger je
nachdem wie das Ganze ausgeht Frau Kelle
Politik Alphatier Robert Habeck sonst
war ja immerhin
ich glaube dass Herr Habeck gerade
tatsächlich ein realitätsschub hat aber
in meinen Augen hat er den einfach spät
deswegen tue ich mich ein bisschen
schwer mit der Beweihräucherung obwohl
ich durchaus sehen kann dass es für ihn
nicht einfach werden wird auf dem
Parteitag dass seine eigenen Leuten zu
erklären gleichzeitig muss man sehen
dass Herr Habeck in seinen Umfragewerten
gerade massiv in den Keller eingebrochen
ist und die werden wieder nach oben
gehen dadurch dass er diese Entscheidung
getroffen hat zwar nicht von seinen
eigenen Partei genossen sondern von von
von aus allen anderen Lagern und aus der
kostet man aufatmen dass dieser Mann
langsam vernünftig wird aber ich tue
mich tatsächlich schwer hier sozusagen
eine ein Lob auszusprechen weil es
einfach nur eine überfällige
Entscheidung ist wo man sich wo ich mich
eher Frage warum kommt sie so spät warum
ist jemand der so im in dieser
Verantwortung steht erst jetzt bereit
etwas zu tun was so glasklar jeder
wusste dass es gar nicht anders geht und
weil die per und wo ist die Perspektive
weiter weil zwei von drei
Atomkraftwerken ist ein Tropfen auf den
heißen Stein und das ist immer noch kein
Konzept also wenn dann würde ich an
seiner Stelle wenn ich seinen Stratege
wäre wenn er schon Streit anfängt in
seiner Partei dann würde ich einen
großen Plan aufstellen und sagen wenn
schon Streit dann sollte es sich lohnen
und dann sollte er nicht nur sagen wir
lassen zwei weiter laufen sondern wir
müssen jetzt erst einmal welche bauen um
uns später überhaupt irgendwann mal
leisten zu können aus den fossilen
Brennstoffen auszusteigen dass wir
während das entfernt von von den
Heiligenschein für Robert Habeck da
stimme ich Ihnen voll und ganz zu dafür
ist es viel zu früh ich glaube man muss
aber an dem heutigen Tag einmal erkennen
dass Robert habe ich einen Schritt
gemacht hat in die richtige Richtung und
das ist glaube ich anerkennenswert und
ich glaube so muss man das auch deutlich
wäre falsch zumindest aus meiner Sicht
wenn man eigentlich egal was der
Wirtschaftsminister macht immer sagt
alles falsch alles falsch man muss dann
glaube ich auch mal sehen dass er in dem
Fall ja auf Druck reagiert hat das ist
sicherlich keine Herzensangelegenheit
gewesen das bereitet ihm sicherlich
physische Schmerzen ganz klar aber eine
Tür glaube ich ist jetzt offen uns
aufgestoßen und auch der Punkt den sie
gemacht haben zu sagen müssen wir
vielleicht sogar über den Bau neuer
Kernkraftwerke nachdenken ja warum denn
eigentlich nicht machen ja viele
Nachbarländer um uns herum auch die
Tschechen beispielsweise frisch mit
einer Ankündigung eine Reaktor aus
Kanada oder kanadischer Bauart künftig
zu bauen also das ist sicherlich eine
Debatte die wir führen müssen ganz klar
aber überhaupt erstmal zu sagen okay wir
verlängern und erstmal nur zwei und dann
drei Monate ist schon mal erster Schritt
und meine Hoffnung natürlich ganz klar
ist dass dem jetzt viele viele weitere
folgen dass der Druck so groß wird und
dass dieses Land diese viertgrößte
Industrienation der Welt eine
Perspektive bekommt für
die nächsten Jahre den Stromhunger den
dramatisch wachsenden Stromhunger den
wir haben zu stillen und zwar zu Preisen
die einigermaßen bezahlbar sind für uns
und für die Unternehmer wie geht es
ihnen eigentlich wenn ich die Frage
stellen darf als Unternehmer mit einem
Wirtschaftsminister der noch nie in der
Wirtschaft tätig war und damit muss ich
leben wir sind in einer Demokratie und
ich habe die Grünen nicht gewählt aber
wie geht es Ihnen persönlich
akzeptiere ich akzeptiere natürlich alle
die da sind und da warte das sie
entscheiden und ich sage jetzt mal das
was hier auch gesagt haben das ist der
erste Schritt in die richtige Richtung
und der wird jetzt dann erkennen müssen
dass er weitergehen muss und ich sag mal
was mich natürlich hinter einer in der
Politik immer wo ich be ich sag mal das
nicht klare Entscheidungen getroffen
werden sonst schrittweise oft wird
werden Dinge gemacht so wie jetzt auch
und das sollte natürlich die Atomkraft
vor allem wenn was ich ja vorhin schon
gesagt habe wenn Frankreich sozusagen
alles aufbaut und und unser Nachbar ist
und man dann trotzdem hier aussteigt das
ist schon der urfehler gewesen damals
dass man gesagt hat entweder steigen wir
europaweit aus oder ja das wird
schwierig ist und wenn die Kernkraft
sicher ist ich sag mal dass es immer
einen Unfall geben kann das wird es
immer geben dass dann muss ich vieles
andere auch abstellen ich sage mal das
war sicher damals eine sehr schnelle und
nicht ganz 100% richtige Entscheidung
die wird sollte jetzt korrigiert werden
wenn wir keine Alternative haben
mindestens dass wir sagen okay das ist
sicherer als das andere und dann müssen
wir dran arbeiten und das wäre eine
Lösung und habe ich wird nicht drumherum
kommen so wie sie es gesagt haben
sozusagen nach im ersten kleinen Schritt
den nächsten kleinen bis zu einem
größeren Schritt dann von
nachzuvollziehen aber das Europa von dem
die sprechen gibt es nicht Europa
handelt eben nicht geschlossen gemeinsam
wir haben keine europäische Armee im
Prinzip wir haben eine Währungsunion
ohne politische Union dabei es war
früher klare Position noch von Kohl erst
Währungsunion wenn man eine politische
Union haben was auch Sinn macht ist die
Instrumentarien da sind wir sehen jetzt
auch bei dem Euro das vieles nicht
funktioniert wir haben natürlich
unheimlich viel Liquidität geschaffen
die uns jetzt auf die Füße fällt und sie
aktiv wird dabei wir haben nicht die
gleiche Stabilität wie die D-Mark die
EZB ist nicht eine Bundesbank das sind
andere Mechanismen sie hat viel Lira
Effekte in ihrer Struktur drin das muss
man fast sehen man darf sich da kein
Wunschdenken machen und weil Frankreich
Atomenergie anders reingings Deutschland
noch lange nicht durch was wir jetzt
machen müssen ist Deutschland zum
modernisieren sie haben es vorhin ganz
schön formuliert dass wir eine Art
Mobilisierung generalmobil stellt man
nicht so militärisch ich habe es nicht
so mit militärischer Auseinandersetzung
sondern wir müssen die Aktivitäten
freisetzen wir haben zu viel Engpässe zu
komplizierte Verfahren zu lange vorlaufe
vergnierungsverfahren es kann doch nicht
sein das sind Baugenehmigung ja oder
zwei brauchen das hier eine Stempel
drauf drücken muss Umkehr machen wenn
vier Wochen nicht entschieden ist gilt
als du ehrlich wir haben ja nicht nur
das Energieproblem wir haben ja auch ein
militärproblem sagen definitiv viele
wenn die Berichte stimmen die ich über
sie gelesen habe waren sie schon 1997
gegen die Wehrpflicht ich glaube für ein
Berufsarmee war die moderne Technik und
Daten erfordert ja andere Soldaten
erfordert als in einer Levi um was wo
sie viele gewehrträger brauchen sind
Hightech Armeen heute wenn sie sehen was
da produziert werden alle großen
westlichen Demokratien haben Berufsarmee
die Amerikaner die Engländer die
Franzosen Italiener ich kenne keiner
mehr außer den Russen das funktioniert
nicht so andere Strukturen haben das
macht schon Sinn dass man das
entsprechend umstrukturiert war es aber
der Fehler war dass wir die Bundeswehr
als Steinbruch für Finanzierung
missbraucht hat wir hatten früheren
Zeiten 200.000 Leopard panzerwerbung 238
wir werden gar nicht in der Lage und
selbst zu verteidigen ohne Amerikaner
kann sich Europa in Deutschland nicht
verteidigen irgendwann habt ihr aber
gerade die Schnauze voll von diesem
komplizierten Europa kommunizierten
deutschen genau der Bedenken und
schwerliche Diskussion haben da muss
Europa in Deutschland auch in der Lage
sein ein Stück Selbstverteidigung selbst
zu bewerkstelligen der
Trump hat durchaus recht gehabt wir
haben versprochen zwei Prozent
auszugeben für
Verteidigungsmaßnahmen wir haben es
nicht erfüllt wir haben es nicht gemacht
immer drumherum geredet und die haben
Munition für zwei Tage nato-vorschrift
ist mindestens 30 Tage wir haben unsere
eingegangene international Verpflichtung
nicht erfüllt die Amerikaner Rügen und